hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear my own little movie review show
the movie i'm talking about today
this is one that i've been wanting to
re-watch for a really long time this is
crawlspace from 1986.
now i remember first seeing this on
cable
probably the late 80s i kind of feel
like or maybe the very early 90s
and a lot of it didn't really stick with
me but for whatever reason i kept i
don't know just like the vibe of it kind
of like stuck with me for a long time
and every time i kept seeing the poster
come up i'm like oh i should really
rewatch that and uh you know see if what
i remembered about it was you know was
still accurate or whatever because i
didn't really remember
too much about it other than klaus
kinski obviously he's very memorable and
it just being about somebody that's you
know stalking around in people's
crawl space you know obviously
so i saw that it was i'd actually plan
to do a different movie this uh on this
particular episode but then when i was
scrolling through i was kind of like i
didn't have that much time to like watch
something in the one that i was gonna do
i looked at it and i'm like oh my god
that's like more than two and a half
hours long and i said i don't really
have that kind of time commitment so
then i started going through like movies
on to 2b so i saw that crawl space was
on there for free and i was just kind of
like okay well this is about the time
that i'm going to pull the trigger on
that so i decided to watch it now this
move i think i maybe only saw it once or
twice and i don't even remember if i sat
through the whole entire thing like in
one sitting the first time i saw it i
just because i just remembered kind of
like bits and pieces of it and i didn't
really know much about it like i said
the only thing i remembered about it was
like the klaus kinsey kinski was like
super creepy in it which you know it's
klaus kinski so of course he's creepy
because he's creepy and everything
because he was just a creepy dude so i
didn't actually know a lot of the stuff
that went on behind the scenes of this
because to be honest
this movie i don't know if i would
necessarily call it uh you know like a
forgotten classic or anything like that
it's not
that
fantastic and honestly if klaus kinski
hadn't been in it i think it probably
just would have been like a fairly
decent low to mid-tier 80s slasher movie
and it wouldn't really be all that well
remembered it would just be because
there were so many of them that came out
at the time so uh klaus kinski being in
this really kind of like elevated it to
a whole other
level and did something really kind of
like
unique with it
now this movie i'll get into i mean the
the behind the scenes stuff about this
movie is
i'm gonna say like more entertaining and
the movie is entertaining i'm not saying
that but the stuff that went on behind
the scenes is like way more entertaining
than the actual movie itself not really
i mean it's funny you could laugh about
it now in hindsight because it was a
long time ago but at the time that
everybody was going through it i'm sure
it was really not a fun time for
everybody that was working on this movie
other than klaus kinski he seemed to
he i don't know if he was having a fun
time either but he really did seem to
relish uh kind of making life miserable
for everybody else
but he wasn't brilliant actor so i guess
he got away with it for a very long time
so uh this movie was actually written
and directed by
david schmoller
now he had done several movies in the
past most notably he had done tourist
trap which i will say uh unequivocally
is actually a forgotten class i don't
think it's forgotten i think of most
horror fans have seen it i think they
even remade it i don't even remember
when that was but taurus trap is
brilliant uh we reviewed that like a
long time ago and i've always really
liked that one and uh so this is one
that he was that he did uh with charles
band
so uh after this uh david schmoller
would go on to work again with charles
band and he would do the first puppet
master movie
so now david schmoller his original idea
for this
um i think that
either the production company or the
producers he was working with
they had been working on that movie
troll which is nothing to do with the
infamous so bad it's good movie troll 2
which was just kind of like an italian
movie made with a bunch of mormons that
was not a sequel to anything
but there was actually a movie called
troll and they had built this apartment
house set
uh to you know to film that movie on now
because this set was still around and it
was a very very nice like apartment
house set uh the production company
wanted to make another uh movie in it
based around our department house
so david schmoeller comes in now he had
been
shopping around this
screenplay that he had written uh which
was about a guy who was a vietnam vet
with ptsd
and when he comes home
his wife and kids have left
and he proceeds to
build like kind of i guess he was like a
prisoner of war
and he proceeds to build like a replica
of the you know cage that he was kept in
or whatever like in the attic of the
apartment building
so david schmoller brings this to the
production company and they're like well
uh you know the vietnam war had really
just when they were talking about making
this movie it only ended just like 10
years ago or is america really ready to
see a horror movie that's kind of based
around the vietnam war which is weird
because house came out in 1986 and that
was also kind of based around the
vietnam war sort of even though it was
kind of more of a horror comedy
but apparently
the production company is like man it's
too soon uh we don't want to really see
anything uh about vietnam like in a
horror movie how about nazis
so david schmoller was like so you don't
want to see something about vietnam but
you're perfectly happy to make yet
another
nazi horror movie at which point the
producers were kind of like if you make
this movie about nazis we will get you
klaus kinski uh who is a very bankable
name obviously
so he was like okay you got a deal uh
i'm gonna make it about nazis david
schmoller apparently
uh was very excited to work with klaus
kinski because like i said a big star he
says that he did not know
prior to filming this movie
how much of a gigantic pain in the ass
klaus kinski was to work with
um and pain in the ass is a gigantic
understatement klaus kinski was
legitimately certifiably insane i think
uh i believe he actually did spend some
time in a in a psychiatric ward when he
was younger for psychopathy uh he was
legit insane and um
very very very very difficult i mean he
was like a [ __ ] nightmare to work
with everybody's i mean you have to have
been
a nightmare to work with if
more than one director has basically
like threatened to kill you so klaus
kinski i mean pr probably most famously
like uh you know he had a very long
working relationship and a sort of
friendship with werner herzog
who also did you know the nosferatu
remake which we reviewed also a while
back
and uh werner herzog also threatened to
kill him on at least one occasion and
made a documentary about their
relationship there was a documentary
about their relationship called my best
fiend uh which kind of
showed uh you know klaus kinski just
like losing his mind he was a he was a
lunatic i mean he was a lunatic
brilliant actor but a lunatic so klaus
kidski gets brought in to do this movie
now
in this movie he's playing because
they're sitting there well they're like
okay well klaus kinski you know however
old he was you know when this movie was
made he was a little bit older i believe
he died of a heart attack only about
five years after this movie came out i
think he died in 1991.
so uh but he was still too young to have
been a nazi so they had to
sort of
you know they kind of had to massage the
script to make it that like his dad was
a nazi and he had been
you know like uh hitler youth or
whatever and then he was just kind of
and his dad was like a war criminal and
he was almost kind of like carrying on
his dad's work or something like that or
he kind of
they're trying to make a thing where it
was like psychologically you know he
kind of followed in his dad's footsteps
even though i think the implication was
initially that he
started out as an okay dude but then
discovered that he had the same kind of
proclivities as his dad i guess
so what happens in this movie is that
there's this apartment building that is
owned by klaus kinski's character uh
whose name is dr gunther carl gunther
and at the very beginning of the movie i
mean there's
it's kind of a slasher movie i guess and
it's kind of like psychological horror
too but there's not any like surprises
you know pretty much from the very
opening scene
that
dr gunther is a murderer and you know
that what he's you know what he's doing
so there's not really
you know it there's not really any
suspense over like oh who the killer is
or is the killer gonna get caught or
anything like that it's basically just
kind of like a series of escalating
set pieces where like you know more
people because there's kind of a thing
too where he really likes to build these
elaborate
sort of traps like to kill people uh
because that's another thing that he
does and uh so it's kind of like almost
kind of like a precursor to saw if you
want to put it that way or i've seen it
compared to
uh the collector as well it's like like
kind of a newer film so it's kind of
like the same kind of thing where it's
somebody that likes to
make traps and things like that
so he has this apartment building and
his big thing is he just likes to rent
the rooms out to foxy young ladies
and
apparently because there have been like
some foxy young ladies living in this
house for presumably a while so he
doesn't kill everybody outright i think
it's only when
somebody starts to like twig onto his
thing or whatever because normally what
he would do
is i mean at the very beginning
uh they show a woman
who kind of like hears something in the
crawl space and she kind of goes up into
the attic to investigate like what the
noise is because she's been living in
this building
and she goes up there
and finds there up in the attic there is
the cage
that has a woman in it whose tongue has
been cut out
and then there's also kind of like
little jars with you know with the
tongue and with other little body parts
and [ __ ] so she's basically like huh
okay uh what's this doing up here and
then klaus kinski kind of you know
sneaks up behind her like slithers up
behind her it's like oh that's a shame i
really liked you and kills her with this
contraption that's kind of like a spear
that comes down through the wall or
something like that it's all very
elaborate
so as i said there's no it's no shocker
as to like who the killer is i mean
klaus kinski is the murderer in this and
he basically just goes through the movie
like killing people and there's a little
bit of conflict with somebody like who's
on to him and is trying to like get him
busted and all this other stuff
so uh and so at the beginning like after
that sort of opening scene
you get this other young woman who is i
think she's like a journalism student or
whatever like at the nearby university
and she's looking for a cheap apartment
so she answers uh the ad she's actually
played by talia balsam and i think she
went on to do a bunch of tv and stuff
later on she might have been in mad men
later on i want to say pretty much
everybody in this had like you know
decent careers uh going forward like all
the women in this
so she shows up and gets the apartment
building it's funny because uh actually
some a guy shows up at first and is like
wants to run the apartment but of course
klaus is like uh no it's already been
taken uh the guy that shows up is the
director david schmoeller
and i saw i was watching this other like
kind of documentary about the making of
this movie
and they said that the the director and
klaus kinski did not get along like so
badly that they couldn't they didn't
even shoot that scene together like even
though it's the director coming up to
the door and being like hey you know can
i have look at this apartment or
whatever so they had to shoot it
separate so that klaus kinsey wouldn't
know like who he was interacting with
which i thought was like very very funny
so essentially uh klaus kinski's
character as i said is you know the son
of a nazi and he's also he started out
as a doctor and i guess he lived in
argentina
and
i think the implication being and maybe
i'm wrong about this but i thought the
implication was that he was a doctor at
first and it was fine
but
then he
euthanized one of his patients or he
killed one of his patients accidentally
or something and then he sort of like
got off on how that made him feel
and so he started doing it just for
funsies like you know euthanizing people
that he thought were not gonna make it
or whatever and then he just kind of
like got his jollies been from doing
that
and then like he started to realize oh
i'm falling in my dad's footsteps at
which point instead of being like hey
maybe i should like you know tone that
back or whatever he decides he's just
gonna go all in um so
uh essentially running away to the
united states after he kills like 67
people like under his watch in argentina
so he escapes to the u.s you know owns
this apartment building and he rents out
the rooms to hot young ladies and then
crawls around in the ductwork
just watching him you know what i mean
doing like crazy kind of [ __ ] now very
weirdly at the very like the first woman
that he's watching
is this woman who's played by i guess
she's credited in this movie as uh tane
uh she's actually tanay mcclure the
daughter of doug mcclure uh which you
know is who was a very famous actor he
was in like
uh humanoids from the deep he was in
like tons of those kind of not journey
to this end of the earth but those kind
of at the earth's core stuff like that
uh all those kind of movies
so she was actually um
something of a sort of like a pop star
type thing like in the 80s i had never
like she sings a bit in this too and is
kind of like a pop star in the movie
like her character is
and i was like oh she has a nice voice
she must really be a singer or whatever
and apparently some of her songs were in
the first terminator movie so if you've
seen the first terminator movie you've
seen some of her songs she was actually
trying to break into acting uh it didn't
really go all that well she was in this
and then she was in some kind of like
skin max level kind of movies like some
soft core type stuff um going forward
but yeah so she's in this as well now
there's a very weird scene like at the
beginning where
she's hanging out in front of her mirror
like being all sexy and her red bra and
underwear and everything and then she
like cuts the the nipples like out of
her bra and i'm just like god do you
know how expensive bras are jesus christ
what are you doing but it turns out
and then like klaus kidski is like up in
the ductwork like watching her going oh
this is some good [ __ ] and then but then
there's another guy who's outside the
bedroom window also looking at her going
oh this is some good [ __ ] you know what
i mean so um but it turns out that the
guy lurking outside the window is
actually her boyfriend and this is like
some like weird sex game that they play
where she likes she gets off on like
somebody like quote unquote breaking
into her apartment
and you know he has a knife on her and
stuff and he's like oh this was a nice
touch like cutting the nipples out of
the bra and everything so there's so
there was a reason for that but yeah so
klaus kinsey's watching this so
essentially
uh that's kind of how the movie goes is
that you know the the new girl comes
she'd be friends like some of the other
uh young women that live in this place
they're all kind of creeped out
by by dr gunther as you would be because
like i said it's klaus kinski um
he can't really help
but be creepy he's just a creepy person
and he definitely comes across and
honestly when i was watching the stuff
about like the behind the scenes uh
stuff about this movie they said like
pretty much all the female actor the
actors on this were
terrified of him because he was like
very clearly unstable uh although it
should be said that 10a
tane mcclure who was in this uh she was
pretty much the only actor that was able
to
like calm him down like he would behave
if she was around
so a lot of times like a lot of the crew
would be like hey you know he's having a
meltdown can you kind of like come in
here and just
be around so he'll like chill the [ __ ]
out uh apparently that was the only
thing that worked on him was like having
her around it he wouldn't uh like act up
when she was around for whatever reason
so uh but they were all kind of like
scared of him and it sort of comes
across in the movie but that's probably
a good thing because they're kind of
supposed to be afraid of him because
he's supposed to be creepy he's supposed
to be like a psychopath and uh you know
these these women all live in these
apartments like alone with this guy and
he's creeping around in their [ __ ]
ductwork and he does other stuff too
like
he has um
just kind of like little weird [ __ ] that
he'll do like he'll stay he'll sit in
the ductwork and like tap like a knife
against like a metal thing like so it
keeps making noise and like people be
like what the [ __ ] is that noise and
it's like it's like driving people crazy
and then he has this one like really
funny thing in one of the apartments
where there's like a little bit of the
baseboard and it's like this little
square and it's like on hinges so like
if the little hinge comes up and then
there's like a little gate back there
and then he can open the gate and like
let rats into your apartment so he does
that sometimes too and then there's like
a later there's a later scene where he
like fills one of the uh one of the
ladies fridges full of rats like lav
rats so there's that kind of whole
situation so he's doing little [ __ ] like
that
but then he also has
a prisoner in the attic who like i said
is a woman whose tongue he cut out and
he didn't kill her because he's like
well i just needed somebody to talk to
so she just lives in there so
essentially he just sits up in his attic
and
uh he writes in his journal so that's
kind of like provides a lot of
exposition about like his past and about
his dad and about how he feels about
things and so he writes in his thing
while she's just kind of sitting there
he also has a white kitten uh and you
know something bad is going to happen to
the kitten and indeed it does although
happily at least they don't really show
it it's just kind of implied because as
soon as that kitten turned up i was just
like oh no
you know what i mean
i hate that i hate that it's just making
it it's funny because i i don't know it
always bothered me it bothers me more
than people getting [ __ ] up at movies
it's like eve i know it's not real but
it's just like i don't know it's it's
getting to a point now where
you know little stuff happening to like
cats and dogs in movies i'm just kind of
like uh i just can't even i don't even
like to think about it but yeah so
something really bad happens to a white
kitten in this but
they don't really show it it's just kind
of
suggested uh and you just kind of see a
little bit of the aftermath but it's not
too bad this is not a real gory film
yeah it's it's kind of like there's a
lot of it's just implication you know
what i mean some of there's a lot of
blood and stuff but
a lot is just implied and a lot of the
people are killed with
traps now there's this one guy who come
who shows up at uh at klaus kinski's
apartment
and he's basically like yeah a long time
ago when you were a doctor in argentina
one of the people that you killed one of
the 67 people that he killed uh was my
brother
and so he has like taken it upon himself
to find this dude so he's been looking
for him for years and years and he
finally finds him so he's basically like
look i can't prove that you did this
stuff but i'm just gonna i know who you
are and i'm just gonna keep watching you
and [ __ ] like that so later on it will
you know shock no one to find out that
uh klaus kinski is obviously gonna kill
this dude and he does it by
making this elaborate it's like a chair
and then he puts like this like a spear
thing like under the seat and then it
has like kind of buttons that you can't
really see like on the arms so like if
you sit in the chair and like put your
hand like that like it's just this spike
just goes right up your butt so that's
how that guy ends up dying and then he
carves a swastika in that dude's
forehead and then like leaves it in the
main character like the main chicks
bathtub so there's that too now another
thing that klaus kinski's character does
i keep calling him that i mean he's
klaus kinskiing he can't i know his
character has a name but you know
another thing that he does which
i don't know because i've seen some
reviews that said well they thought that
this made him a little bit more
sympathetic i don't know if it does i
think it just makes him seem like more
psychotic
it almost to me it almost came off like
he was like the reason that he's making
all these traps and stuff i got the
feeling that he was almost
trying to like absolve
responsibility like off of himself for
killing people by you know putting
himself at one remove it's like oh well
it wasn't me that killed them it just
happened that this guy sat in this
elaborately trapped chair that i made so
it's kind of like his own fault and the
thing like where the the trap where the
little white kitten gets killed it's
just kind of like this charm cheese was
like oh well you know they don't say
this in the movie but it's almost kind
of like oh well the cat shouldn't have
crawled in there so it's like the cat's
own fault
so i kind of feel like there was that
because one thing that he does after
each person that he kills in the
apartment building
is he cuts open he cuts his finger and
puts blood on a bullet and then he puts
the bullet in the revolver or whatever
and then spins it and he does like
russian roulette
and so he'll hold it to his head and if
it doesn't go and obviously it doesn't
shoot him
then he says so be it so i guess he's
saying well if i kind of feel like he's
saying well if god didn't want me to do
this or fate didn't want me to do this
then
then if the gun would go off and i would
die and he's perfectly happy with that
but because it didn't happen that must
mean oh well i'm okay and i can continue
what i'm doing and also like i said
that's also kind of like a little bit of
letting fate decide uh his outcome i
guess so as the movie goes on he gets
like more and more
deranged uh at one point he's just like
watching all these like nazi propaganda
films and like putting makeup on and
like smearing lipstick all over his face
and it's putting the hat on and saying
he's his own judge durian executioner
and all this other kind of crazy [ __ ] so
it's just like this crazy
um like i said it's very straightforward
the story there's no twists and turns
there's no surprises or anything like
that you pretty much know how it's going
to go
but honestly
i mean klaus kinski in this is just so
it really gives something to this movie
that it absolutely would not have had
without a minute i think it would have
been an okay movie without him
but it wouldn't have been it would have
just been like okay it wouldn't have
been like all that memorable uh him
being in it really elevates this one to
kind of something special i also really
like i like the apartment house set they
designed it's really nice and i like
that the entire
movie is shot inside the apartment
building there is one shot that's
outside like outside the window and that
was also shot inside like on a sound
stage
so the movie has like this real
claustrophobic um type of vibe to it
which i think works really well
so let me talk a little bit about one of
the things that came out of this movie
that's probably well probably that's
definitely more popular than the movie
itself
uh there was a nine minute documentary
film
that the director david schmoller made
uh several years later i think it was in
1999 and it's called please kill mr
kinski
the reason that it's called that is
because when he was working on this
movie like i said david schmoller he was
very excited to work with klaus kinskin
hadn't heard like what a pain in the ass
he was
so
he's like literally the first day the
guy shows up on set he didn't like any
of the clothes that had been picked out
for him like for the wardrobe so he was
like [ __ ] this i'm not wearing any of
this he goes out to like these really
expensive like clothing restaurants buys
a whole entire new wardrobe of clothes
he liked
charged it to the production like the
production company the movie and then
when the production was over he took all
the clothes home
so i mean just right out the gate they
said in the first 48 hours of this shoot
he had started literally six fist fights
like on the set
uh people were threatening to quit
it was just kind of like and he was
doing [ __ ] i mean he'd always be late he
just like screamed and cried he didn't
want to do anything and it was just kind
of like after a while because david
schmoller like after the first few days
of the production he's like what the
[ __ ] is up with this guy like he's a
psychopath and then he started going
back and like reading some interviews
with him and he's basically klaus kinski
directors he really did not like being
told what to do he didn't like being
told what his craft was he thought
directors were [ __ ] they didn't know
what they were doing and he only he
could direct klaus kinski you know what
i mean so he would get to a point where
you know like on the set of this movie
uh he would get mad like
the director would go action like a
normal director would and he would start
like flipping out no
all my whole entire career it's like all
these directors are shouting action at
me and i'm just i should decide like
when i'm ready and all this other kind
of stuff so they had to like make all
these concessions to him because and he
was just completely completely
unreasonable they said just all the
demands he made were completely
unreasonable you couldn't like tell him
anything they basically had to film him
pretty much all the time because
he would not he just would not be
managed they said you can't say action
you can't say cut he's like i'll decide
when the scene's over
he wouldn't um
read a lot of the dialogue that was in
the tag he's like i don't need to say it
um he would say stuff like that so they
said after a while like the director he
was like i basically had to start using
like reverse psychology on him where he
where he would do us we would do a scene
and i'd be like oh we don't need any of
that dialogue and just to be spiteful he
would be like oh well i'm gonna do the
dialogue then he's like well that's good
because that's what i wanted anyway so
they really had to he he got the feeling
that like klaus kinski was just being a
dick on purpose because he hated
directors and he wanted directors to
quit
and so i i kind of feel like david
schmoeller was like well i'm just not
gonna let him get to me like that so he
just kind of started to like so they so
they basically all had to like work
around him and like manage
what like his behavior which uh
by all accounts i mean was atrocious it
was so bad
that uh one of the producers who it's
funny because uh in the documentary that
david schmoeller made uh please kill mr
kitsky he doesn't name the guy he says
the italian producer but since it was
only one italian producer like on this
uh everybody knows who he's talking
about they said that guy said allegedly
that after a few days of putting up with
uh kinski's shenanigans on set
the producer was basically like how
about uh we just have him killed and
collects the insurance money
uh at which point i mean because they
wanted to fire him
after a few days because they said this
is just not worth it but the production
company i think was vestron pictures and
uh empire and some like other the
financers were like no you can't fire
him because he's like the the bankable
name uh you know it's this movie's not
gonna go anywhere unless he's in it so
you have to have him in the movie so at
that point they just had to like figure
out essentially like i said how to work
around him but after that producer like
early on was just kind of like maybe we
could kill him for the insurance money
you know and the director is like
calling the other producers being like
um he says that we should kill him and
he's totally serious
and they're like no no you can't do that
obviously but by the end of the shoot um
pretty much everybody on the crew was
basically say and they said that they
would just say it like right in front of
klaus kinski's face too they would just
go to the director and be like please
kill him please kill him it's like
everyone was just over his [ __ ] [ __ ]
now apparently like all of his uh you
know antics
made the movie go like two weeks over
which is kind of a big deal for a lower
i mean it's not that big a deal i guess
for like a big
production but for something as low
budget as this um that's a pretty big
deal that it went like uh that it went
two weeks over just because he was being
such a pain and he just wouldn't he
wouldn't do another he wouldn't do two
takes he would you know he was just like
a nightmare to work with and every
single person said that and pretty much
everybody by the end of the shoot every
single person on the cast and crew
wanted him dead so
like i said that's not the only direct
that's not the only movie he worked on
where people were like actually three in
fact klaus kinski was so aware of how
everybody hated him on this set
that the scenes where he was doing the
russian roulette he started getting
paranoid that somebody was actually
gonna put real bullets in that [ __ ] so
he would actually blow his own head off
like uh during the filming so he would
like keep checking it and keep checking
it and keep checking it like before they
did the scene
so on some level he must have known like
what a [ __ ] monster he was because he
knew that people were like out to get
him but it seems like i don't know it
seems like rightfully so like people are
out to get him and it's just kind of
like i don't know it's kind of funny
because i mean it's funny in retrospect
because he was okay he was a brilliant
actor and he's actually really good in
this he's super super creepy um which is
what you want like for
an ex nazi murderer uh who
makes traps to kill people and like
leers at people through through their
crawl space so it's always good like if
you're creepy for that
but
it's just he you know he's such a
brilliant actor and he got away with a
lot
but
i mean it's funny
if you weren't there but i'm sure if you
were like working on the movie it must
have just been [ __ ] hell i mean you
just wouldn't want to go can you imagine
like having to work with somebody like
that every day so in a way it's like
it's funny but then i'm thinking well
that's really shitty though because
you're making life
you know hundred times more difficult
for everyone around you just because of
your massive ego and because you know
think you know better than everybody so
i don't know was it worth it probably
because as i said if klaus kinski wasn't
in this movie it probably wouldn't
completely forgotten and but honestly
though i kind of feel like this movie
it's not completely completely forgotten
but it's largely forgotten uh because as
i said if he wasn't in it it just seemed
like it
nobody would talk about it at all
because there's not
you know it's not like super creative or
anything like that i think it did okay
at the box office i don't know like it
didn't lose money but
uh it got kind of bad reviews and you
know everybody said it was just kind of
a big nothing
kind of movie but it's you know or if it
was just like really ugly really
disturbed and it wasn't you know it just
wasn't a good time which i kind of agree
with that it is kind of disturbing but
not by today's standards um i think it's
pretty tame
but
honestly and like i said i will agree
though that hearing all the stories
about klaus kinski uh
about the [ __ ] [ __ ] he was doing
behind the scenes and like all the
trouble that they went to getting this
movie made uh was probably more
entertaining than the movie i do like
the movie though i think it has like a
lot of really cool uh cinematography i
really like the apartment set like how
claustrophobic it was um i think
actually the cinematographer on this was
uh might have been sergio salvatio i
think who worked with uh lucio fulchi
quite a bit i think he did the beyond
and a couple of his other ones uh so
there's that so you had a lot of talent
going on behind the camera but
it's funny how much it got like kind of
overshadowed by
what a [ __ ] nut case
klaus kinski is uh he just you know
wherever he went he just kind of just
psyched the [ __ ] out and that's what
everybody remembers this is definitely
worth watching though um you know if for
nothing else for his like [ __ ] creepy
ass performance and
just the crazy like traps that he comes
up with there is like something really
skeezy about this movie uh in the sense
that it kind of makes you want to wash
afterward it's kind of that sort of
it's kind of i don't want to say it's
like sleazy sleazy but it does have a
little bit of that sleaze to it and it
is very very 80s like everyone has very
very 80s hair
very very 80s clothing it's just like an
80s explosion
so
so i think it's a good thing to watch
for that as well i think i i don't
remember that much about it from seeing
it the first time but i'm actually glad
i rewatched it because and like learned
about all the behind the scenes [ __ ]
because that that was just hilarious and
honestly i'm
i'm actually flabbergasted that all of
the [ __ ] that went on behind the scenes
of this i'm
i'm amazed that a movie this decent came
out of that [ __ ] because you just
wouldn't and a fairly successful move
like i said i think it you know it
didn't um it didn't lose money but i
think it did okay i think it didn't do
all that great it didn't get good
critical reviews and again it's one that
a lot of people don't really seem to
remember from the 80s for whatever
reason i saw it a couple times back on
cable like i said and i didn't really
remember a lot about it but
something about it must have resonated
from all those years ago because when it
came up again like when i was scrolling
through on 2b and i was like oh yeah i
remember that when i really need to see
that again so you know i'll watch
anything with klaus ken's candidate
because like i said he's a [ __ ]
psychopath but yeah uh this is on 2b for
free at the moment at least as of this
recording so uh please go check it out
and tell me what you think about it and
uh let's have a discussion about what a
[ __ ] nightmare klaus kinski was cause
yeah i think we talked about we talked
about him a little bit when we talked
about nosferatu because he was uh he was
in that as well and was also super super
creepy in that like i said he just he
couldn't help but be creepy he was just
like a creepy dude but uh yeah so this
is kind of this is kind of an
interesting uh sort of quasi-slasher
from the 80s that doesn't really get
talked about a lot so i'm kind of
curious as to who's seen it or if you
haven't seen it if you have seen it let
me know in the comments and that will do
it for this flickers of fear i will see
you guys on the next one bye